في اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وبعد ساعات من ختام القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه في كييف ارتفعت وتيره الحديد
عن الاصول الروسيه المجمده في الغرب
القاده الاوروبيون اكدوا خلال القمه
انفتاحهم على الاستجابه لطلب اوكرانيا
بمصادره هذه الاصول وتحويلها لصالح اعاده
الاعمار في اوكرانيا لكن الامر يحتاج الى
مزيد من الوقت وافقى خبراء في الاقتصاد
والقانون لا سيما ان دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
لم تصل الى موقف موحد في هذا الشان وقد
جاء تحرك الاول بشان الارصده الروسيه
المجمده والبدء في مصادرتها من الضفه
الاخرى من المحيط الاطلسي بمنام واشنطن
على وجه التحديد ويتوقع ان تسمى الخطوه
الامريكيه في تحريك الحلفاء الاوروبيين
لاتخاذ خطوات شبيهه يتم بموجبها مصادره
مليارات الدولارات من الارصده والاصول
الروسيه